[MUSIC PLAYING]
JONATHAN GERRISH:
My name's Jonathan,
and I work on the Mobile Ninjas.
We're a team within Google,
passionate about testing
and testability.
If you've ever written test for
Android before, it's likely,
you've used some
of our products--
Espresso, Robolectric, or
the Android Testing Support
Library.
And together,
these tools combine
for billions of
test invocations,
both within and
outside of Google.
So today, there's
a general consensus
within the software development
community of the virtues
of writing tests.
Sure, there's a cost
for writing tests,
but it's an accepted
one, and it's
one that quickly pays dividends
throughout the lifecycle
of your project.
Tests provide fast
feedback on failures.
A bug caught early
on in development
is far cheaper to fix than after
you deployed your application.
They give you a safety net for
making changes to your code.
You're free to
re-factor, clean up,
and optimize, safe
in the knowledge
that you're not going to
break any of the existing
functionality.
And what's more, a
suite of readable tests
provides the living,
breathing specification
of your application's behavior.
Now, in software
development, there
exists the concept of
the testing pyramid.
It's made up of three layers--
unit, integration,
and end-to-end tests.
And as you go up the pyramid,
you're gaining fidelity,
but this comes at the expense
of test execution time.
It also gets harder to maintain
and debug these kinds of tests.
But just like a
rock band, where you
need a perfect
blend of musicians
to create that great track,
each layer in the pyramid
is equally important.
You're leveraging the
advantages of one layer
to compensate for
trade-offs in others
to produce a holistic
automated testing environment.
We recommend a 70/20/10 split
as a general, healthy guideline.
And now, while the rules of
these pyramids still apply,
some of the unique
characteristics
of Android development have
introduced some difficulties
along the way.
So unit tests, due to
their need to be fast,
will run on the
local workstation.
And integration and
end-to-end tests,
due to their need to run in a
really faithful environment,
tend to run on a real
or a virtual device.
And so, separate
tools have evolved
at each layer of the pyramid.
Robolectric, or the
mockable Android framework
for your off-device unit tests.
Espresso and the Android
Testing Support Library,
for those on-device tests.
Now, Android's got some
really familiar core concepts,
such as getting a handle to
your application context,
or maybe driving your
activity lifecycle.
And each of these tools
has its own distinct APIs
and ways of doing
things for achieving
these exact same tasks.
Now, this has led to something
of a test-writing crisis.
As a developer, it's
hard, sometimes,
to know what tools
are available for use
and which of those
are recommended.
Having multiple
tools at each level
has led to an
explosion of styles,
each with their own
distinct patterns and APIs.
And this, in turn,
leads to a lack
of mobility between layers.
Tests can't easily be
re-factored or reused
between layers in the pyramid
without being completely
rewritten for a new tool.
To discuss this further,
let's orientate ourselves
with what constitutes
a well-structured test.
So there's some following
common patterns that
define a well-structured test.
And so, we generally
break tests down
into three clear sections--
given, when, and then.
And I like to separate
them with a blank line
to clearly demarcate them.
So given some predetermined
state of the system,
when you execute an action
that you wish to test,
then verify the new state of
the system or some behavior
has occurred.
Be sure to name the test after
both the condition you're
testing and the
expected outcome.
Keep the test focused on
very specific behavior.
And then, test all your
behaviors independently.
And less is always
more with tests.
These guidelines will
help you keep each test
understandable in isolation.
Use common setup methods,
only for scaffolding.
This is maybe
creating the object
that's under test and wiring
up some of its dependences.
Let's take a look at the problem
of the explosion of styles,
and we'll highlight this
using a simple test case.
We'll have a single activity
with one button that
responds to a click, sending an
intent to the Android system.
And I'm going to walk you
through this test case,
comparing the different styles
of Mockito, Robolectric,
or Espresso.
So first up, let's
consider Mockito.
Now mocking is a
really powerful tool,
but it's one that's often
overused and sometimes,
used inappropriately.
Mocking your own
classes is great,
but while mocking
the Android framework
may seem like a
great idea at first,
it can soon lead down a
path of difficult problems.
Many Android classes
are stateful,
or they have complex
contracts, and these
are really difficult,
or even impossible,
to satisfy with mocks.
So even though we
don't recommend it,
let's just start by taking
a look at one of these tests
and walk through it using
the Mockito framework to mock
the Android framework.
So in the Given section, we
can [? new up ?] our activity
under test, but look.
We first of all,
have to step out
some of the Android
framework behavior
in the superclass activity
so that it responds
as we expect in our tests.
Now, this introduces
some problems.
First of all, we're partially
stubbing the class under test.
And this means we're not
testing the true behavior
of that object under test.
And furthermore, it brings
with it excessive stubbing,
which introduces all this
undesirable boilerplate.
And that quickly
becomes distracting
from the true
intention of your test.
For the When
section of the test,
to execute your code
under test, you'd
have first needed to register
an ArgumentCaptor earlier
to get a handle on that click
listener, which you would then
vote manually to call the code
that you're wishing to test.
Now, with this
approach, you can soon
descend into an undesirable
mess of ArgumentCaptors,
stubbing calls, and
answer invocations.
Finally, in the Then
section, to obtain intent
sent to the Android
system, you're
going to have to use
another ArgumentCaptor.
And mocking the Android
frameworks in this way
tends to force you into testing
implementation details, when
you want to be testing
behavior instead.
And furthermore,
these drawbacks have
tended to lead developers to
build their own abstractions
to isolate Android.
This, in turn, leads to
its own set of problems.
Firstly, you're introducing
another layer of cruft
into your application.
And secondly, you're
introducing texting
gaps, where bugs can hide.
And we believe that while
you should architect
your application
very thoughtfully,
the limitations of
the tools shouldn't
dictate your application
architecture either.
So let's see how this looks
like with Robolectric.
Robolectric is the popular
open source testing framework.
It allows you to follow the best
practices surrounding mocks,
as you're able to use real
Android objects in your tests,
rather than having to
program your own stubbing
behavior in each test.
It runs on your local host,
which means it's very fast,
making it ideal for unit tests.
Robolectric tends to create
tests that read a lot cleaner.
So let's walk through
each section in turn.
In the Given section, we
can simply bring an activity
into the resume
state for our test
just by calling Robolectric's
setup activity API.
In the When section, we're
able to use real Android SDK
APIs, such as Find View by
ID, to get a hold of the view.
And then, Robolectric's click-on
API, safely click on that view
and invoke the code
that we wish to test.
And finally, in
the Then section,
we again use Robolectric's
own testing APIs
to check that the intent
was sent to the system.
See how much cleaner
this version is?
We're focusing on the items
that really matter in the test,
and we're free of all those
extra pieces of distraction.
Now, Espresso is an
UI testing framework,
and it runs on a real
or a virtual device.
It provides you with a
really realistic environment.
The trade-off here is a
much slower execution speed.
You're building up
your entire APK,
deploying it to the device,
and instantiating the test run.
Waiting for the results and
then collecting those back
on your local workstation.
All of this is adding
valuable development cycles.
Now, the exact same
Android concepts
exist here, we're just
getting hold of an activity,
clicking a button, and
then, verifying an intent
was sent to the Android system.
Here, though, as you'll see,
the APIs are very different.
Let's step through
this one together.
So in the Given section,
we'll use the activity test
rule, which comes from the
Android Testing Support
Library.
This can be used to
start an activity,
bring it to the resume
state, and provide us
with a handle to
it in our tests.
For the When section, we can use
the Espresso view matcher APIs.
We'll find the view
in question, and then
safely click on it to invoke
the code that we wish to test.
And finally, in
the Then section,
we use Espresso Intents
Library to capture that intent,
and verify that it
was the one that we
wanted sent to the system.
Notice here that, while a test
has many similar structures
to Robolectric tests-- the
example that we saw earlier--
the syntax is very,
very different.
So while each of these
testing frameworks
have contrasting
strengths and weaknesses,
it's this explosion
of styles that's
really become the big
problem for writing tests.
Who, in the audience,
has been using
Robolectric to write tests?
Raise your hands.
And what about Espresso?
And who's using both?
We often hear developers
talking about,
I need to write a
Robolectric test,
or I need an Espresso test.
But we'd much rather you
be thinking about writing
an Android test instead.
We feel, as a developer, that
no matter what kind of test
you're writing,
you shouldn't first
have to think about environments
and tools and libraries
that you'll need.
We believe you
shouldn't have to suffer
the mental load of having to
learn multiple sets of APIs
for doing exactly
the same thing.
And of course, you
should have the freedom
to re-factor and
reuse your code,
no matter where you
choose to run it.
So what if there was
only one set of APIs
that you needed to learn?
And now, imagine also,
being free to focus
on writing your test, rather
than considering those tools
and libraries and environments.
Well, to make this a
reality, today, we're
launching Android Test.
It's part of Jetpack.
With Jetpack, testing is
now a first-class citizen
of the Android toolchain.
We're unifying the
development experience
around a canonical, high
quality set of APIs,
that will reduce the
boilerplate and eliminate
the number of tools
that you need to learn.
Naturally, Kotlin and
support is included,
allowing you to write
beautifully concise tests.
And, of course, all of
this will be open sourced.
We love contributions from
our community members.
We're going to satisfy
developers' needs in each
of the four key
sections of the test--
remember, Scaffolding,
Given, When, and Then.
Scaffolding encompasses the
configuration and control APIs.
Think getting a hold of
that application context.
For your test scaffolding,
Android JUnit 4 Runner
is used to execute your tests.
You can use the
instrumentation registry
to get a handle to that
application context.
Well, today, we're
excited to announce,
for the very first
time, you can now
use these APIs for both your
on and off-device tests.
The next section of a
test is the Given section,
and here, we're going to provide
two key categories of APIs
for you.
Firstly, the Android JUnit
rules from the Android Testing
Support Library will
become part of Jetpack.
And we're soon adding more APIs
to help drive the component
lifecycle for you in tests.
As you've seen previously,
the activity test rule
is used to start
up your activity
and make it available to
test in the resume state.
You probably used this API
running on a device many times
before.
Well, today, this API, too,
will be available for tests
that run off-device, as well.
Secondly, we'll be providing you
with a set of Android test data
builders.
These will help you
construct Android objects
that your code and the
test will interact with.
Many of the Android
framework classes
that you need for setting
up your test state
are difficult to create.
Often, there's no
public constructor,
so they can't be
instantiated for test.
Perhaps they're final, so
mocking is out of the question,
either.
And sometimes,
they're just plain
clumsy to instantiate with
any degree of brevity at all.
So we're including Android
test builders within Jetpack
to give you a concise way to
set up your test environment.
They produce readable
code, that fluent way
to create the Android components
that you need to interact with.
And of course, they're portable.
Android test data builders
work for both your on
and off-device use cases.
The third section of
a well-structured test
is the When section,
exercising the code under test.
Usually, this is
just simply a case
of calling your
own code directly,
but when you're
writing an UI test,
it's likely that you'd reach for
the Espresso View Matcher APIs.
Today, we're happy to announce
that Espresso, too, is
joining Android Test Jetpack.
Espresso View APIs are fluent,
and they read beautifully.
You've used them for your
on-device tests for a while
now, and today, we're
providing preliminary support
for these tests in the
off-device use case also.
The final part of a
well-structured test
is the Then section.
This is where you
make assertions
on the state of the system
in response to an action.
So firstly,
Espresso-Intents, too,
is going to be joining Jetpack
as Android Test Intents.
Those intents APIs that you've
been using for your own device
testing, great news.
Today, they, too, will run
in your off-device tests.
And finally, we're also
releasing an assertions library
to help reduce the
boilerplate in your tests.
Using traditional
JUnit assertions
can lead to tests that are
not immediately readable.
See here, how easy it
is to get the actual
and the expected
arguments mixed up?
And Android uses a lot
of integer constants
for efficiency,
but this makes it
difficult to comprehend the
error messages in tests.
At Google, we love to use Truth.
It's our own open source, fluent
testing assertions library.
Using a fluent
assertions library
is a great step to producing
more readable code.
And writing the tests
become much more easy, too,
because you can lean on the
built-in support of your IDEs
auto completion feature.
So to help you write concise
tests against Android code,
we'll be releasing a
set of truth extensions
for Android, which
reduces the boilerplate,
reads beautifully, and gives
immediately meaningful error
messages.
Of course, these
assertions will work
across all environments, both
the on and off-device tests.
So with Jetpack Android Test,
we'll be bringing you the tools
that you need so that
you can concentrate
on writing beautifully
concise, easy-to-read tests,
without first, worrying
about libraries or tools
or environments.
A single set of canonical
APIs for common tasks
that will reduce the
boilerplate, leaving
your test clear and readable.
And that are
environmentally agnostic,
allowing you to run the
tests either on-device,
on your local workstation, or
perhaps, in a Cloud Test Lab.
And now that I've shown you how
to use this unified set of APIs
that decouple the act
of actually writing
a test from where
it's going to run,
I'll hand you over
to my colleague,
Stefan, who's going
to show you how
you can run these tests in
the new simplified world.
Stefan.
[APPLAUSE]
STEFAN RAMSAUER:
Thank you, Jonathan.
Welcome, everyone.
10 years Android, quite amazing.
I also want to say a big welcome
to everybody who is joining us
at the Livestream today.
At Google, we
believe that testing
should be a fundamental part of
your app development strategy.
Let's bring back the pyramid.
As we can see, our
friend with the Jetpack
has solved the API dilemma.
Now that we got one
API to rule them all,
it's really easy to start
writing tests for Android.
No more excuses.
We can start with a simple
test for our business logic,
usually, a unit test.
And over time, we can
add more and more tests.
Once we start implementing
the UI for our application,
it might be worth adding
an integration test.
This just became a
fluent experience,
since both layers
support the same APIs.
No more context switching.
Great.
But that's not the only
use case where the new API
becomes really handy.
Let's imagine we have
an integration test that
got too large and complicated.
I have seen many of those tests.
It's just too convenient to
test business logic and UI
flow in one single test.
At Google, we don't
like those tests.
They are hard to read, and
they tend to become flaky.
Small, well-focused
tests are much better.
So let's re-factor this
large, complicated test.
Re-factoring a large test
can be a very painful task.
Who in the audience has
experienced this recently?
Raise your hand.
Here's some good news for you.
If the original test was
written with the new API,
this task becomes much simpler.
We still have to test
our UI, and we'll
keep this part in
the integration test.
This layer provides
high fidelity,
and we don't want to lose
that for our UI test.
The rest, mainly business
logic, can directly
go into the unit test layer.
Here, we gain speed
since we can run
off-device on a local
[? travel ?] VM.
So let's verify the
re-factoring together.
We still have high
fidelity for the UI test.
That's good.
We gain speed.
Even better.
And the tests are
decoupled and less complex.
Nice job.
Your coworkers will thank you.
So let's run those tests.
But wait.
We still have to choose
a runtime environment.
It's not always trivial
to pick the right one.
We also have to work in
multiple source sets.
The combination of runtime
environments plus source sets
will lead to an explosion
of test configurations.
Just imagine how hard
it will get to choose
the right configuration.
Should I run on a
device or off a device?
And don't we need to
run the entire test
suite on our continuous
integration server
before we submit?
And you all know the
feeling, after we kicked off
the test run, waiting
eagerly for the results.
Oh, no.
Hold the Submit.
One of the tests is flaky.
I'm pretty sure many of you
have been in this situation.
Flakiness is one of
the biggest pain points
for developer productivity.
So what if there
was a better way
to set up your test
harness, execute
your tests in a
reliable environment,
with unified test results?
Today, we are proud to
announce Project Nitrogen,
the new single entry point
for all Android tests.
Nitrogen is fuel
for your jetpacks.
With our expertise of
running billions of tests
a year, we had to build the
fastest and most reliable
test executor.
Nitrogen covers the entire
testing lifecycle, from setup
to test execution and reporting.
Nitrogen provides deterministic
behavior across different
build systems.
It will be fully integrated
in Android Studio.
At Google, we
already use Nitrogen
to test our own apps, such as
Gmail, Google Maps, Photos,
YouTube, and many more.
Nitrogen is highly extensible.
It provides APIs
for test authors
to customize the test
invocation at any point.
Nitrogen will be fully open
sourced later this year,
but let me give you an
overview, starting with setup.
Nitrogen connects your test
to any execution environment--
on-device, off-device,
or in the Cloud.
It installs required
test artifacts.
And if necessary, it can run
custom fixture scripts for you.
Let me show you how this works.
First, Nitrogen finds
and provisions a device.
This can either be a simulated
device, a virtual device,
or a real device.
Once the device
is ready, Nitrogen
installs the application,
under test, and the test.
Nitrogen then,
stages any test data
dependencies and sets
device properties.
If additional
setup is necessary,
it can all be done here.
Let me give you examples.
Setting up a network tunnel,
starting a hermetic server,
gaining/granting
permissions, and much more.
And finally, it
prepares the device
for the next step,
test execution.
There are many ways how we
can run an Android test.
It's a little bit like
running in the real world.
Here, we have sprints,
mid-distance, and long distance
runs.
We also have different
environments--
track running, road running,
cross-country running,
and mountain running.
A unit test on your
local workstation,
it's like a sprint--
as fast as possible
to the finish line.
The test suite on your
continuous integration server
is the marathon.
The goal is to get
to the finish line
and not to fail along the way.
Today, these tests are
executed in different ways,
from the command line
from Android Studio,
or triggered automatically
when you submit.
With Project Nitrogen, this
will become consistent.
We provide a
well-defined protocol,
and are unifying all the
Android test offerings.
Nitrogen uses our own
device infrastructure
to run your tests--
Android Orchestrator and
Android JUnit Runner.
You can already enable the
on-device infrastructure today.
It has been available
since Android Studio 3.0.
The Orchestrator
collects your tests
and kicks off test execution.
By running each test
in a separate process,
shared state is minimized
and crashes are isolated.
Moreover, your
tests are executed
in a familiar JUnit environment,
provided by Android JUnit
Runner.
The Orchestrator
collects all test
results, additional
artifacts, and streams
it back to Nitrogen. Nitrogen
provides a unified reporting
format for these test results.
In addition, it provides a huge
selection of test output data,
such as Locket, screenshots,
video, profiling data, battery
performance, and much more.
All artifacts are
scoped per test.
This means that, for
example, a Locket snippet
is reduced to the test method.
No more digging through
hundreds of lines of Locket.
So let me show you how Nitrogen
improves the entire testing
flow on Android.
First, Nitrogen finds the
device and configures it
for the test run.
Second, it runs
tests in isolation,
using the Orchestrator.
And finally, while
tests are running,
Nitrogen host site
infrastructure
will be streaming the test
results from the device,
pulling down all
test output data,
and feeding it back to you.
With Nitrogen, all
this complexity
is hidden from
you, whether you're
running a test on Android
Studio or on a CI server.
Nitrogen is the single entry
point for all Android tests.
It works from a
sprint to a marathon.
Nitrogen can regress the
device in a Firebase Test Lab,
reliably running your tests,
returning unified test results.
Nitrogen supports Google Cloud.
From your workstation, you
can deploy and run tests
on the real device or
on a virtual device.
Nitrogen works seamless
seamlessly with Robolectric.
Now, we can treat Robolectric
as a simulated device.
With Robolectric 4.0, we
have made big improvements
in startup time and
memory consumption.
Robolectric 4.0
is released today.
[APPLAUSE]
And if this is not
enough, Nitrogen
supports your custom needs.
For example, if you have
an in-house device lab.
Allow me to summarize.
Previously, you had to
learn multiple approaches
for doing the same thing.
Tools lacked the mobility
to move between the layers
of the pyramid.
You had to choose wisely.
We have reduced
the cognitive load
by providing you a
single set of APIs that
work across environments for
both on and off scenarios.
And a single entry
point for Android
tests with the flexibility to
customize any point in the test
invocation.
Jetpack with Nitrogen,
is a giant leap forward
in test automation for Android.
Write your test once,
run it everywhere.
[APPLAUSE]
This is just the beginning.
Now, you have both the
tools and the knowledge
to accelerate your
testing experience.
I strongly encourage
you to check out
our codelabs, especially
our latest addition,
building Android
apps with Bazel.
Bazel is the open source
version of our internal
build system, allowing
you to build large Android
apps at Google scale.
If you have further
questions, or if you
would like to discuss
your testing strategy,
come find us tomorrow
morning at 11:00
AM in the office hours
tent in section A.
We hope you enjoyed
our session, and we
would love to hear from you.
So please, take a moment
to submit your feedback.
And with that, happy testing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]